hello there this is how you can tell
that I am in post-convention mode hairs
gross wearing a sweatshirt and
sweatpants and I just feel like I have a
thin layer of scum all over my person
yay business and networking
I put lipgloss on for you guys because
girls who wear lip gloss usually have
their lives together
it is Thursday here on it's Grace and it
is just the tip just the tip Thursday I
think will be a really great name for
this day I think I'm gonna call it just
the tip day - tea tea I don't know my
tumblr to ask you guys what did you want
to learn how to do today and someone
said hi I will prepare for graduating
college and cope with the constant what
are you doing with your life questions
and clearly I am an expert on life so I
came up with 25 things you can do or say
when someone asks hold on I ordered
martinis because this is not the picture
of a adult where was I oh I came up with
a list of 25 things you can do or say to
that family member or friend that asks
you what are you gonna do with your life
next let's do this I'm recently a penis
cataria so I'm probably gonna eat a dick
find Jesus I hear he's not a Panera
Bread make it one bread bowling for
10,000
[Music]
Jesus oh my god is that Willie Nelson
old people love Willie Nelson you know
just think you're doing something like
oh you got something on your face
oh I'm sorry sister awfully insensitive
inquisitiveness oh my god it's about all
of them the brothers and sisters wives
people loved Baba and be honest with you
I just shat myself I'm gonna be honest
with you I just stabbed myself I'm gonna
be honest with you I just had myself my
landline is ringing I'll add that on the
list
doodlee dude you know there are a few
potential buttholes and I'm hoping to
get a finger in and that's about me do
you remember that one time Eddie Murphy
or Michael Jackson middle of music and
also Jesus I think when I google image
search three body holes you just said to
do that's the beginning of doodly-doo
taped a Leroy I'm doing good
I'll talk about it but I think I have
heard a go I'm gonna go to the moon on a
space boat but sometimes Jesus you know
I do have aspirations up I don't need a
back anyway well there you go there by
25 tips for how to answer the question
what are you gonna do with the rest of
your life clearly I don't know
goodnight
sorry my landline is ringing are they
wrong on Jenkins